ever wonder what the Shazam movies look
like without their VFX I decided to look
into the amazing work that goes into
turning these movies into the Fest of
flying fight scenes devious monsters
super powers and a lot more so one of
the first things they had to sort out
was how to make the flying sequences
look legit so the Shazam team used
devices that are becoming pretty popular
for flying known as tuning fork rigs I
love my life they strap the actors into
the front part as if they're being fed
to a giant for dinner and then
manipulate their movements slowly and
carefully
I Can Fly And as opposed to a normal
Fork the actor harnessed in can rotate
on several axes giving a super realistic
set of movements for when the VFX team
does their thing later the studio put
out some great shots of them using the
rig like this shot of Shazam flying
through the mall maybe it's just me but
I think it's cool that even in an era of
CGI there are still like literal crew
members pushing the rig physically
forward and helping the actor move and
everything it kind of feels like a
throwback to old school Practical
effects of course that's just so that
shazam's body movements are exactly how
a real person would look if they flew I
mean I'm assuming the few times I've
flown in my dreams have been super
awkward the director of both Shazam
movies David F Sandberg is a big time
VFX guy and he wanted to understand the
process for his actors in the first
movie so he got rigged onto one of these
tuning Forks to see what the experience
was like that's dedication you guys
according to Sandberg it's way harder
than it looks and it also takes a ton of
upper body strength you know who it was
kind of easy for though Mark Strong
that's because The Man Behind Dr
Savannah made sure he was prepared
you've got to have a strong call he got
to have a strong call so I work really
hard to make sure I did he trained for
like two weeks on the rig before
shooting started so he was totally great
at it by the time they filmed and TBH he
looks pretty confident in shots like
this when he's floating down to do all
his villainous civility I'll tell you
what's not villainous though subscribing
to the channel just saying but it wasn't
all tuning fork rigs as with most movies
when there's a lot of levitation and
flying the Shazam movies rely on their
fair share of wire rigs which then get
painted out by the VFX team it's cool to
see like in the same scene with Shazam
flying through the mall where they used
a tuning fork rig they also used wires
and they didn't just use them for actors
they also used them in that epic shot in
the first Shazam where a bust starts to
fall off a bridge and Shazam catches it
got a buzz in my head that insane shot
involves trapping an 1800 pound bus down
with wires so it could tip halfway off
the bridge but not fall over completely
that's some high stakes wire rigging
right there and of course the VFX team
had to then paint out those wires just
like with the flying actors speaking of
flying shots Shazam was full of great
uses of VFX both in the air and on the
ground for example there's a pretty
iconic shot in the first movie that was
also in the trailer showing Billy
jumping off a roof getting struck by
lightning and turning into Shazam as you
can see from the footage without VFX
it's just a shot of the actor Asher
Angel jumping onto a pad with a green
screen or in this case blue as the
background it's also so cool to see the
various flying and fighting shots often
both at the same time with and without
the VFX like this set of varied shots
that shows you what it looks like with
the VFX and without it that includes the
mid-air fight between Shazam and Dr
Savannah the VFX team balled out on this
one basically creating the entire shot
you can see the two actors flying around
and fighting in a room completely made
of blue screen so the VFX Squad had to
paint in literally every frame of the
scene that's called earning your
paycheck people also I think it's so
cool when you can see how a shot goes
from filming to VFX added in to finished
like this series of shots where we see
how Shazam falls to the ground but then
stops short an inch above it and while
the flying shots and the bus shots are
dope maybe the coolest use of VFX in the
Shazam movies are the monsters
specifically the ghoulish creatures
representing the seven deadly sins
obviously the VFX team had to create
these cool looking villains because
finding actors who look like a 10 foot
tall demon is not easy sometimes it
relied more on completely CGI effects
while other times it was a combo of real
people and devices with CGI added in
like in this shot of Shazam flying
literally through one of the monsters
you can see how it was created with CGI
then the actors were painted in
afterwards you can Zach Levi filming his
part in the fully blue room and then how
he was added back into the finished
scene it's a team effort and I'm here
for it in fact in this shot you can see
all the real people who were in the
frame and then the CGI effects they used
for the final look same with this scene
where Shazam fights a monster
speaking of monsters there was a monster
of a spoiler thrown out when the final
trailer for Shazam Fury of the Gods came
out that of course was the brief scene
that included Wonder Woman director
David F Sandberg was pretty annoyed
about the spoiler and made it known
online but then an odd thing happened a
rumor started that gal hadn't actually
filmed her part and that they'd use deep
fake technology to put her face onto
another actor's body and while that
would have been a pretty cool feat for
the VFX team to pull off it wasn't true
Sandberg decided he'd show footage of
himself directing her of course there's
still a tiny glitch in The Matrix here
cause he wasn't actually on set with gal
he was directing her via a video call on
his laptop because he had Visa issues
for the scenes that they were shooting
in England so I'm sure there are
conspiracy theorists out there who would
accuse them of Faking the footage of him
directing gal what even is real anymore
am I right either way Sandberg is
adamant that this was not a VFX stunt
and gal is actually in the movie okay
I'm gonna go outside I didn't say Shazam
a bunch of times to see if it turns me
into a superhero you don't know until
you try right guys and if you have
thoughts about the dope VFX from the
Shazam movies pop them in the comments